machen wir weiterhin mit er ist der held
seines landes vom komiker zum
präsidenten zum hoffnungs gebenden
gesicht des krieges ja ukraines
präsident wolodimir selensky unser
reporter philipp iad auf der iss zu
seelands gießen wurzeln gereist und zwar
in die stadt
kritisch dort wo er tatsächlich
aufgewachsen ist
[Musik]
ich bin hier im luftschutzkeller eines
hauses im kreml eine stadt in der keine
südlich von kiew und das ist nicht nur
irgendeine stadt sondern das ist auch
die heimatstadt des ukrainischen
präsidenten vor die mir sehr ans kinn
und zwar bin ich in dem haus in dem er
geboren und aufgewachsen ist wurde zur
schule gegangen ist ich bin mit meinen
kollegen her gekommen um mit den
menschen zu sprechen die ihn von früher
kennen und kaum waren wir da gleich
begann auch schon der luftalarm die
meisten menschen bleiben in ihren
wohnungen weil sie es nicht schaffen so
schnell runter zu kommen das ist ein
riesiges gebäude ein riesiges gebäude
riesiger gebäudekomplex einzelne
menschen sind hier untergekommen tja und
jetzt warten wir bis der luftalarm
vorbei ist gestern haben die russen zum
ersten mal wirklich die stadt selbst
beschlossen also die heimatstadt von
lenski wollen sie eigentlich angekündigt
hatten sich auf dem don was zu
konzentrieren die stimmung in der stadt
ist sehr nervös und viele befürchten
natürlich auch dass die russen genau
hier zuschlagen könnten nicht weil
dieses gebäude irgendein militärischen
wert hat sondern um einfache nutzen
zeigen sie lenski jetzt zerstören auf
deiner heimatstadt auch das haus in dem
du aufgewachsen ist
rhodia ist wie ein normaler junger
aufgewachsen wie alle unsere jungs im
hof
er ist herumgerannt herumgesprungen zur
schule gegangen und als er zu dieser
comedy sendung gegangen ist war das für
uns ein zu großer stolz dass jemand von
hier mit dem wirt zusammengewohnt haben
so ein star geworden ist wir waren sehr
stark
und als er zum präsidenten geworden ist
waren wir so richtig stolz wir haben so
eine hoffnung in ihn wohl hier ist
einfach das wurde nicht über ihn gesagt
ein clown ein schauspieler nein das ist
in erster linie ein mensch und jetzt
seit der krieg begonnen hat sind wir von
ihm komplett beeindruckt
wir stehen hinter ihm mit allem was wir
haben wir glauben
schaut nur wie in der letzten zeit
gealtert ist sehr stark das sind die
nerven die schlaflosigkeit
so witzig wie auf der bühne ist so ist
er auch im echten leben sein vater ist
auch so ganz humorvoll es sind gute
menschen
[Musik]
der vater war sehr gesprächig er hat
sich nie versteckt wenn die männer sich
draußen getroffen haben ist er auch dazu
gekommen er hat sich mit ihm unterhalten
domino gespielt die mutter saß auf der
bank der vater mit den männern
der russische präsident sagt dass sie
von nazis und unabhängigen regiert
werden das ist schwachsinn weil wir ja
war nie ein nazi oder drogenabhängiger
rudolph ist ein auto wir haben kein
narzissmus alle menschen sind gleich
gottseidank gäste krieg noch nicht bei
uns hoffentlich kommt er nicht sonst
obwohl er näher kommt
wie kann man das machen sie klauen
morden vergewaltigen diese unmenschen
die leute lieben sie töten babys kinder
in mario pohl haben sie vor drei tagen
ein zwölfjähriges mädchen entführt